now as we warned you last night the
disastrous border bill is nothing more
than a blatant attempt by Biden and the
left they just want to shift the blame
for his border crisis squarely onto the
shoulders of Republicans uh this is his
and his alone and speaking at the white
house uh today Joe tried to do just that
take a look so I'm calling on Congress
to pass this bill get some my desk
immediately but if the bill fails I want
to be absolutely clear about something
the American people are going to know
why it
failed I'll be taking this issue to the
country and the voters are going to know
that it's not just a moment just at the
moment we're going to secure the border
and fund these other programs Trump and
the maggot Republicans said
no because they're afraid of Donald
Trump afraid of Donald
Trump every day between now and November
the American people are going to know
that the only reason the border is not
secure is Donald Trump and his Maggie
Republican
friends that is a big lie we'll break it
down in a second now echoing Biden's
remarks his press secretary Ken Jean
Pierre added this at today's White House
briefing take a look at this so I mean
they voted they've actually voted first
two years no responsibility it has I'm
not saying that Democrats have not been
in control the first two years that's
not what I'm saying I'm saying House
Republicans have gotten in the way they
have they have purposefully gotten in
the way in trying to fix what's
happening at the border oh so now it's
all the Republicans fault that Joe
Biden's wide openen border with 10
million unvetted illegal immigrants that
he has no responsibility in that um I
thought they kept telling us though that
the border is closed and the border is
secure like Democrats have been telling
us this for three years in case you
might have forgotten I'll remind you
take a look sounds to most folks like a
crisis well look it's way down now we've
now gotten control precisely that the
border is closed nor could I have been
clear and continued to be so which is
the border is closed the United States
will continue to enforce our laws and
secure our border the Border um we are
working to make the Border more secure
you're confident this Border's
secure we
have a secure border and that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
and our Administration we agree that uh
the border is
secure well they' pedal that lie for
three years we all know the truth
they're lying to us that has not stopped
the media Mob Of course from backing
Biden in all those attempts to blame
Republicans they they're now joining on
board they take their talking points
seriously take a look you have one of
the slimmest majorities in the house in
history don't you have to compromise to
get something done what you pass in the
house can't pass in the Senate Mr
Speaker you know that this is almost
entirely a border security Bill and its
Provisions include longtime GOP
priorities that the party
restrictionists could never have passed
only a few months ago are you listening
Mikey just because Donald tells you to
jump doesn't mean that you have to put
America's sec security at risk last
night a bipartisan group of senators
unveiled a compromise bill but the
Republican Speaker of the House says
it's Dead on Arrival but the Border I
mean we're looking every day at the
invasion of migrants and they're playing
a Time game with politics on this
couldn't that pressure put to bear in
their home States Dead on Arrival the
speaker of the house vowing to tank the
historic border deal reached by both
parties in the Senate and on defense
over accusations it's Donald Trump
pulling the
strings all right let me let me educate
Joe Biden and all his willing accompli
of liars that I call the media mob
Congress is not at all not one bit
responsible for this n National Security
nightmare that Joe Biden created the
media mob they have been silent they
have been complicit now for three years
they have allowed the big lie that the
border is secure and closed to go
forward unchallenged they have not been
showing you the American people on other
channels the disaster that is going on
that Joe created at our Southern border
Biden has was handed the single most
secure Border in our nation's history
now here's what really happened with the
stroke of a pen this is a pen Joe Biden
revoked all of Donald Trump's efforts to
exclude illegal immigrants from the
Census he strengthened DACA he ended
Trump's interior enforcement rule he
halted all border wall construction he
ended Asylum agreements with El Salvador
Guatemala Honduras he ended the
remaining Mexico policy and he even let
title 42 expire Biden never needed
Congress to fix any of this he can
reinstate all of those policies that he
revoked just as he undid them with a
stroke of a pen but that's not going to
stop the mob the media the liberal Joe's
in the media from remaining complicit in
the Biden border crisis they have not
covered this story for 3 years they have
steadfastly refused to be showing on a
regular basis how bad This Disaster is
at our Southern border caused by Biden's
fail policies and let me be very clear
the Senate border Bill they're all
pushing it's an unmitigated disaster and
by the way the only good news is Mitch
McConnell admitted earlier today it's
dead and not only would this bill do
nothing to secure the Border it could as
written actually codify
all of Biden's aiding and abetting of
illegal immigrants and law breaking into
law and they know deep down it's total
BS in fact earlier today on my radio
show Senator Ram Paul joined us from
Kentucky said some Republican Senators
wanted to keep all of the details that
would they were putting in this bill
away from people like me specifically
because they knew how bad this
legislation is for conservatives and
basically it's not me they didn't want
you to hear about it and by the way this
is what he said to me take a listen I'll
tell you what I do hear behind the
scenes is as I hear from people in our
caucus who talk to sources high up who
say we need to make sure Sean hanity is
not talking about this or laa Ingram
because conservatives that's why they
kept it secret and that that was said
out loud in our CAU that said this has
to be kept be and it cannot be allowed
to go in front of the conservative talk
show host it cannot be allowed to
discuss that's why it's secret how how
dare we may actually tell the American
people that's all of you the truth now
meanwhile earlier this evening House of
Republicans their effort to impeach the
DHS secretary Alejandro mayoras well it
ended up as a tie but then one flipped
so they can bring this bill back for
example Steve scalise was not there
today Utah Congressman Blake Moore
switched the vote from yes to no rightly
so uh and by voting for The majority
that means Congressman War can
reintroduce the legislation at a later
date and with Steve scal to return plus
special elections looming in New York
District 3 by the way early voting is
going on now that'll be a week from
Tuesday and then California we have an
election in May Republicans will have a
chance to secure a stronger majority
hopefully they do and a greater
likelihood of passing the impeachment
that is still on the table hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else